kotaku Australia reports that the
Australian Federal Court has found Val
guilty of breaching Australian Consumer
Law due to steams lack of a refund
policy I'm Lucy and welcome to this
Judge Judy gamespot news update team did
not have its current refund policy in
place when proceedings commenced in 2014
involving allegations that valve was in
direct breach of Australian law which
states it is a breach of the Australian
Consumer Law for businesses to state
that they do not give refunds under any
circumstances including for gifts and
during sales the australian federal
court ruled that valve had made false or
misleading representations in the terms
and conditions contained in three
versions of its steam subscriber
agreement and two versions of its sting
refund policy easing cloche consumers
were not entitled to a refund for
digitally downloaded games purchased
from valve via the steam website or
steam client in any circumstances valve
had excluded statutory guarantees and
all warranties that Goods would be of
acceptable quality and valve had
restricted or modified statutory
guarantees and or warranties of
acceptable quality although parcells
games to Australian consumers through
Steam it does not have a physical
presence in the country which was a
major cause of contention kotaku
Australia reports that Valve stated that
it did not officially trade in Australia
but only provided online access to video
games through a client which they felt
did not fall into the definition of
goods as it is defined in Australian
Consumer Law valve also stated that a
same subscriber agreement is based on
the law of the state of Washington USA
and not that of Australia today justice
Edelman ruled that Valve was indeed
conducting business in Australia due to
the three aforementioned representations
in the subscriber agreement which
involved conduct in australia australian
competition and consumer commission
chairman rod Sims stated that the
federal court's decision reinforces the
forum based businesses selling goods
and/or services to Australian consumers
can be subject to Australian Consumer
Law obligations including the Consumer
Guarantees
is also the first time courts have
applied the extended definition of goods
to include computer software in the ACL
it will provide greater certainty where
digital goods are supplied to consumers
through online platforms consumer issues
in the online marketplace are a priority
for the ACCC and we will continue to
take appropriate enforcement action to
hold businesses accountable for breaches
of the ACL so do you think valve are in
the wrong let me know in the comments
below or come find me on Twitter I met
Lucy James games for all the latest
gaming goings-on keep it gamespot